♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO THE STATE OF
TEXAS ANNOUNCED THEY ARE GOING
TO START BUSSING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, MORE THAN A MILLION
HAVE COME THROUGH TEXAS AND THE
LAST YEAR, TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND WE CRITICIZED THAT.
IT'S A PRETTY FUNNY IDEA BUT THE
REAL QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU KEEP
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO RIGHT TO BE
HERE OUT OF THE COUNTRY IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
AND ACTUALLY, TO BE FAIR, THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS, GREG ABBOTT,
MAY HAVE COME UP WITH A PLAN TO
DO THAT.
SO THE GOVERNOR OF THE PROVINCE
IN MEXICO HAS JUST ANNOUNCED HE
PROMISES TO CURB ILLEGAL
MIGRATION NORTH.
HE'S DOING THIS IN RESPONSE TO
SOMETHING GREG ABBOTT DID.
ABBOTT IMPOSED STRICT SAFETY
CHECKS ON TRUCKS COMING FROM
SEVERAL PROVINCES IN MEXICO SO
THIS IS A HUGE ECONOMIC PROBLEM
FOR MEXICO.
ABBOTT SAID HE WOULD LIFT THE
NEW REQUIREMENTS IF THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT OF THESE PROVIDENCES
THOUGH MY PROVINCES AGREED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM MIGRANTS.
ONE PROVINCE HAS NOW AGREED, WE
HOPE OTHERS FOLLOW.
WE WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS
FROM THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS,
GREG ABBOTT.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE, TUCKER.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE
IMPLEMENT IT WHAT WE CALL
ENHANCED SAFETY INSPECTIONS OF
EVERY COMMERCIAL VEHICLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER OF EVERY
BORDER CROSSING FROM MEXICO INTO
THE STATE OF TEXAS.
AND IT HAD A PROTECTABLE RESULT,
AND THAT IS IT SNARLED TRAFFIC
FOR MILES IN MEXICO, BASICALLY
CRUSHING ECONOMIC CONDITIONS IN
THESE STATES AS WELL AS IN THE
COUNTRY OF MEXICO AND HAVING
SEVERE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENT IS
FOR BUSINESSES IN MEXICO AND THE
PREDICABLE RESULT IS THAT THESE
GOVERNORS OF STATES THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO TEXAS WOULD BE
KNOCKING ON OUR DOOR BEGGING FOR
RELIEF.
AND IF THEY BEG FOR RELIEF, WE
ARE DEMANDING THAT THEY
IMPLEMENT SECURITY MEASURES THAT
WILL REDUCE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT STANDARDS
THAT WE WILL BE APPLYING TWO
DIFFERENT STATES THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO THE STATE OF TEXAS.
YESTERDAY WE ANNOUNCED AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
NUEVO LEÓN.
TODAY WE ARE HAMMERING OUT
DETAILS WITH TWO MORE STATES
THAT ARE ADJACENT TO TEXAS, THEY
HAVE BORDER CROSSINGS IN TEXAS
THAT WILL HAVE SOME DIFFERENT
MEASURES.
DIFFERENT MEASURES THAT ENHANCE
SECURITY, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
FROM THEIR STATE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS AND THEN THERE WILL BE ONE
MORE STATE GOVERNOR THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH TOMORROW TO TRY TO
HAMMER OUT DETAILS WITH HIM.
ALTOGETHER, WE EXPECT AND WE
DEMAND THAT ON THE MEXICAN SIDE
THEY FINALLY STEP UP AND STOP
THESE LOW-WATER CROSSINGS AND
OTHER ACTIONS THAT ARE ALLOWING
THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
CROSS THE BOARD.
IF THEY FAIL TO DO THAT, WE ARE
TO CONTINUE WITH OUR RIGHT TO
INSPECT EVERY SINGLE VEHICLE
COMING ACROSS THAT BRIDGE INTO
THE STATE OF TEXAS REGARDLESS OF
THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES IT
POSES TO MEXICO.
>> Tucker: SO I MEAN, THIS
SUGGESTS THAT POLITICIANS IN
MEXICO HAVE BEEN ABETTING THIS
MASS MIGRATION INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S ABOUT TO GET WORSE, AS YOU
KNOW, NEXT MONTH, WHEN THE
BITING OF MINISTRY SHOULD LIFT
ANY KIND OF COVID RESTRICTION ON
EMIGRATION.
WE ARE EXPECTING A HUGE WAVE
INTO YOUR STATE.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS ENOUGH TO
STOP IT?
>> LISTEN, THIS IS A MEANINGFUL
STEP TO REDUCE IT.
THERE ARE OTHER MEASURES THAT
THE STATE OF TEXAS HAS TAKEN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
THIS AS FULLY AS WE CAN.
WE'RE THE ONLY STATE IN THE
HISTORY OF AMERICA TO BUILD A
BORDER WALL.
WHERE LAYING DOWN MILES OF RAZOR
WIRE, BLOKE NOMADIC BOAT
BLOCKADES ON THE RIVER TO
PRESENT PEOPLE FROM COMING
ACROSS.
WE ARE TURNING THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER TRYING TO CROSS THE
BORDER OR DO CROSS THE BORDER,
TURNING THE BACK.
THOSE WHO MAKE IT THROUGH, WE
ARE ARRESTING AND PUTTING IN
JAIL, SO WE ARE USING MULTIPLE
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE THE
MIGRATION INTO THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
TUCKER, ONE CONSEQUENCE OF THIS,
YOU MAY SEE HEIGHTENED MIGRATION
ATTEMPTS IN OTHER STATES LIKE
NEW MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA WHERE
THEY ARE BEING LESS RESISTANT.
OUR JOB IS TO MAKE IT DIFFICULT
AS POSSIBLE FOR THE CARTELS TO
GET PEOPLE TO MOVE PEOPLE ACROSS
THE BORDER IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
OUR GOAL IS TO PUT THE CARTELS
OUT OF BUSINESS, MAKE THEM LOSE
MONEY, TRYING TO SMUGGLE PEOPLE
INTO THE STATE OF TEXAS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I MEAN, TEXAS IS ALL YOU CAN
CONTROL.
YOU ARE ONLY THE GOVERNOR OF ONE
STATE AND THIS SEEMS